the mayor of Virginia Beach Virginia is
calling the most devastating day in his
city's history a workplace shooting that
left 12 victims dead at a City office
building police say a longtime city
employee opened fire on his coworkers
Friday afternoon and didn't stop until
responding officers shot and killed him
the gun battle was described as
long-term and police say the shooter who
has yet to be named publicly was armed
with a semi-automatic handgun that was
equipped with high-capacity magazines
and a silencer the complex where the
violence unfolded is also home to the
city's courts municipal offices and fire
and emergency services Errol Barnett is
in Virginia Beach with the latest
Erol good morning good morning look in
many ways we are in the heart of
Virginia were in the center of town of
the state's largest city and people here
are reeling thankfully the quick
response by police likely saved many
lives but the gunman who is believed to
be a Public Works employee chose to
carry out his attack in the same
building in which he worked you can see
that right behind me it's a place where
at any one time there can be up to 400
people a city employees dialed 9-1-1
Virginia Beach police were closing in
for officers entering the public
utilities building locating the gunmen
by following the sound of gunfire they
immediately engaged with the suspect and
I can tell you that it was a long gun
battle between those four officers in
that suspect police chief james severa
described a chaotic scene many times
when we talk about an officer-involved
shooting situation it may be minimal
rounds by the suspect and by the police
officers this was well beyond that one
officer who was struck was saved by his
bulletproof vest
the suspect eventually shot dead but not
before he killed one person outside the
building and 11 more inside victims
found on three separate floors four
others including the wounded officer
were also shot while terrified employees
hid inside office
they said this day in there until the
cops got there to let us come out there
was probably about 20 of us in an office
crammed in we barricaded the door
did you hear any gunshots yes yeah we
did
my hope is she come walk out call me let
me know she had the church after hearing
of the shooting Anthony Daniels waited
in a parking lot to see what happened to
his wife
she was eventually reunited with him but
the grim task of identifying the victims
and notifying their families remains our
hearts ache over the senseless violence
that has been inflicted upon the
Virginia Beach community today
meanwhile chief severa was adamant about
how his department will handle
discussing the shooter we're gonna
mention his name once and then he won't
be forever referred to as the suspect
because our focus now is the dignity and
respect to the victims in this case now
police are holding a press conference
this morning to provide further updates
we do know that at least three people
are in critical condition right now
police are waiting to identify nexif to
identify relatives I should say until
all next-of-kin have been contacted so
this will be an anxious day for so many
people as the community here absorbs the
loss of at least 12 of its residents
Michelle oh wow just still so incredibly
chilling so much going on so many people
with comments but one person who herself
has been the victim of a mass shooter
with Gabrielle Giffords she had this to
say we're only a hundred and fifty one
days into 2019 and there have already
been a hundred and fifty mass shootings
the fact that our nation's leaders
continue to fail to protect us should
feel outraged fuel outraged in every
American you know the police chief said
yesterday you know these lives are
changed forever it's the reason why they
only want to say that suspects name one
time they actually had had a community
program planned today to deal with mass
shootings obviously cancelled since some
seniors matter either scenario so that
people in the community would know what
to do there will be a night of prayer at
the bridge Church in Virginia Beach this
evening at 6:00 p.m. and obviously our
hearts
go up to all those families including
the ones who were just worried about
relatives but ultimately were reunited
that's just it's apparently you hear
about the text messages that go out in
that moment and cannot imagine what that
would be like to not know about your
loved one in those safety it impacts so
many people who yawn just the relatives
and the victims yes everyone in that
community is feeling it everyone